i want to start by saying congrats on
the movie
i put on twitter that i was going to
talk to the both of you
and something that struck me with the
amount of people that said that you had
written
john some email and then you deleted it
after seeing the first movie
could you sort of explain this yeah no
the story is i saw the movie with my
kids in the cinema
and i we were all blown away like
genuinely i thought it was one of the
best movies of the year and i
i i occasionally reach out to other
artists to say
look man i or a woman i think that was
an extraordinary
an extraordinary piece of work um
and i wrote the email and then i just
felt like i was too cheesy
and i didn't know him so i just deleted
it i never sent it
and when did he learn that you were
going to send him this email
well he emailed me then a year later
about the movie so
it sort of worked out that's actually a
great journey
right uh it's amazing um yeah true yeah
for both of you guys um with the quality
of the first film
how much are you like when they when
they talk to you about taking on a role
how much are you sort of like whatever's
on the page i know john's going to
deliver and how much are you looking at
the script
do you know what i mean could you sort
of talk about that uh
the one thing i can say is that uh i
came on board of the film
almost at the tail end of it uh where
killing already
kim you know looking like he just came
from war
but um and i did not have the whole
script
i only had my scenes
and that was uh satisfying you know i
mean because i
knew how well he did with the first one
and uh
and the fact that he was all the whole
the same team was around
you know came uh together again to make
the second one
that was quite uh reassuring that uh you
know
again they they have a very you know a
good idea where they're going with that
story and
certainly i wasn't quite concerned about
uh
you know how the story came about or
what the story is
on the second one so i just joined
blindfolded uh
yeah it was beautiful i mean the
experience was beautiful
uh for you what was the question oh
basically so when john reached out to
you
was it sort of like yeah i'm in i don't
even have to see the script or were you
like i need i need the script
oh no i mean i i always read the script
i mean
um that's that's the basis of the choice
i mean i knew how
excellent the first movie was i and i
was ex i i was just
blown away by how perfectly formed a
director john krasinski was and how he
what a master of tension he was um it
just seemed to come out of nowhere and
and then i read the first or this script
and it's a quiet it was quite a slim
document you know it's like it was like
70 pages or 80 pages or something like
that because it's mostly
stage directions obviously but uh it was
amazing and
it was everything that i'd hoped it
would be and then you know as jimin said
the fact that the whole team
were coming back and the movie felt more
like a continuation
of the first story as opposed to a
traditional sequel
right you know uh so it was yeah
straight away
yes yeah um before i run out of time uh
i'm a big fan of the marvel movies
like everyone who reads collider um and
i believe you're doing an episode of
what if
or oh yes yeah sure right i'm like yeah
you're like wait i am in that house yes
i am um could you
uh have you recorded your lines for that
yet can you tease anything about it
that means
uh no i i really uh honestly
there's not much i can share with you
it's been so long
and uh i've recorded something and i
can't really
get my head around what we've uh
recorded so far and uh
what the story is about you know
i'm really have no clue
sure well that's the thing that i think
so many people are excited about with
what if
which is it's like an alt version of
what could have happened yes
and so i'm i'm very excited to see this
animation
yeah yeah i i think it'll be exciting
just based on
what if for example